he's an entrepreneur television
personality real estate magnate and
investor he was number 17 on Forbes as
2011 celebrity 100 list he even
considered running for president of the
United States of America
he's Donald Trump and here are his top
10 rules for success in your book the
art of the deal you said that money
really isn't that important that just a
means of keeping score to playing the
game that excites you I love the game I
like the money and the money is
certainly a method of keeping score but
I don't do things for money I do things
because I enjoy doing that really
sometimes can translate into more money
than you would have made if you went
just after the money never ever give up
you can change and you can move around
but never ever give up I know people
that are very smart they went to the
Wharton School of Finance with me I know
other people that aren't as smart and
those people are the top people in
industry today and the top they just
were tougher they didn't give up and the
smart ones had everything on their plate
that always come in with the A+ on the
tests and the good boards and everything
else but when they ran into problems
they didn't know how to solve the
problems like the guys that weren't as
good and it's very seldom that you see
something other than this happen so
never ever give up a lot of that is all
in the details you've got to be into the
details because if you're not they'll
come back to haunt you so oftentimes you
know life is in the details well
business also is in the details you have
to be very careful you have to watch the
dotted eyes because you can really lose
tremendously if you don't watch those
details so we discussed that and as
Robert likes to say probably more than I
do
that's the little finger but it's all
about the details it's very important
you want to be totally focused you can't
take your eye off the ball when I had
troubles in the early 90s a major
article
came out and it said very strongly
everything he touches turns to gold and
I believed it so I'd go out with models
at night instead of working but that
wasn't good and I remember I had a big
lease coming up and there was a big show
and I went to the show I said don't
worry fellas you can handle the least
you'll get it done when I came back they
didn't get it done and I would have had
it done a hundred percent and then the
market crashed in the 90s so I had
trouble but it was sort of an amazing I
wouldn't want to do it again it was an
amazing test of yourself
can you handle pressure how are you
under pressure are you smart you know
when when everybody's coming at you you
know the worst employee is a good
employee a bad employee is fine because
you fire that person right away a great
employee is phenomenal you want to keep
them and cherish them they're fantastic
but a good employee you never sort of
fire them but they never lead you to the
next level they just keep their job
they're sort of too good to be fired but
they're not good enough you're never
going to do great so I always say the
worst employee isn't a bad employee it's
just a good or average employee Gary
Player the great golfer he was a little
guy very little but he worked really
hard and he had a great statement but
he'd go the harder I work the luckier I
get and he wins the US Open you have all
these big handsome guys he's big giant
guys and they're hitting the ball a mile
and you have Gary Player and Gary Player
would win the open he'd win the Masters
hid win this it win that and he said you
know hey he in the US Open he had a
5-iron to one foot from the hall and he
ended up getting a birdie and wins the
US Open right and he came off to green
eye I know I've heard the statement
before but I heard it from him in a
meaningful way they said what do you
think Gary what is it he said all I know
is I've been working very hard and the
harder I work the luckier I get I
thought it was an amazing statement
sometimes in life to be successful
oftentimes most of the time you have to
follow your instincts you have to follow
your gut you have to your parents may
say wrong
you're whoever may say wrong but you
have to do it so much of success is
seeing yourself as victorious you have
to see yourself you have to really
believe in yourself and sometimes it's
hard you know you've had failures you've
had weaknesses you've had other things
you have to see yourself as a one-man
band don't rely too much on other people
because they'll let you down you have to
see yourself as victorious and to be a
winner you have to think like a winner
if you don't think like a winner it's
just never going to happen many people
have been asking about my desk and the
fact that I have so many papers on my
desk it's actually very neat I know
where everything is
but if you look around I mean there's a
lot of stuff the fact is I'm busy I
always notice that busy people people
that are very successful in many cases
have a lot going on on their desk I have
papers from deals I have papers from
just about everything I like to read up
on things I like to study what I'm doing
so therefore you have a lot of action
going on your office now some of the
writers some of the ones that aren't so
smart they talk about the desk
negatively they say oh isn't it terrible
Trump has so many papers on his desk
let's analyze everything on the desk and
they do the best and they fail but the
fact is I've noticed over the years
successful people have a lot going on on
their desk my desk is in my office my
desk is a very important part of me and
frankly it's a very important part of my
success everything I do comes right
through this desk so if it's not
perfectly neat if there's a lot of
action I think that's okay I actually
think that's a good thing you have to
love what you do and I'm not going to go
over that long but it solves a lot of
problems because when you love what you
do would you really love what you do you
work harder I mean I have friends that
don't love and you know I tell the story
a Wall Street Titan big guy but I was
richer than him and I'm richer according
to Forbes
tritscher than him so I like that you
know I like that but there's big Wall
Street Titan he's a big name he has a
son and his son is a wonderful human
being which is amazing because the guy's
a horrible a horrible person but he's
one of the biggest guys on Wall Street
so he wants his son Alex I'm going to
use the name Alex it's not his name but
I don't want to get this guy in any more
trouble with his father the knee or
''tis Alex isn't the strongest character
the father is a brutal vicious killer so
the father has a big firm on Wall Street
and he wants Alex to go into the firm of
course you know come on Alex get in
there get in there
in the mean time all these kids are
graduating from Wharton and Harvard and
Stanford and they're just eating Alex's
lunch he doesn't have a chance
he doesn't have a chance and he doesn't
like it he's not liking what he's doing
you got to love what you do
he's not like him so one day but he
can't leave because of his father I
actually told why don't you leave your
father's brutal the father's just
killing the guys tell him you don't have
what it takes I'm sorry dad oh this is
great
so I say you got to leave the father you
got to leave him he said I just can't
Donald so anyway he's a spoiled guy he's
a member of a very good golf club in
Westchester which is a rich place in New
York and he's on one of the committees
and he's on the greens committee and
they put him in charge of redoing the
course they're doing this big renovation
of the course it's a very good cut Club
and he's there every morning at 5:00 in
the morning he doesn't leave he did such
an unbelievable job the contract is
respected him everybody respected him so
the wife comes up he's doing so great
Donald he's so amazing and they give him
an honor and this is a tough group of
people that have this Club you know the
club members and they're difficult
they gave him an honor the club came in
under budget faster by two months he did
an unbelievable job and the quality of
the work was ten times what they ever
anticipated so they gave him a medal I
said you know Alex you were to go and do
this for a living you ought to be a
builder whether it's houses or clubs or
golf courses renovation or this oh my
father would go crazy and never let me
so Alex went back
to Wall Street where he was miserable
and a year later he quit and he started
doing renovations of houses and clubs
and different things and he's doing
great so you've got to love what you do
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because I knew the band asked
me to I hope I pronounced out properly
so if there's a video that you want me
to make on a famous entrepreneur leave
it in the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
you think of Donald Trump do you love
them do you hate them leave it below I'm
going to join in the discussion look
forward to hearing what you have to say